HERE TO UNPACK THAT AND MUCH
MORE SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
MERRY CHRISTMAS AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
YOU CAN NAME ONE THING?
>> MAKING DONALD TRUMP LOOK
BETTER EVERY DAY.
I DON'T KNOW.
THE PROBLEM, PETE, IS THE LEFT,
THE RADICAL LEFT HAS BIDEN IN
A BOX.
HE CAN'T MAKE THE ADJUSTMENTS ON
THE BORDER HE NEEDS TO SECURE
THE BORDER.
REMAIN IN MEXICO WAS IMPOSED BY
THE COURT.
HE CAN'T CHANGE HIS BORDER
POLICY BECAUSE THE LEFT WON'T
LET HIM.
WE CAN'T EXPAND DRILLING FOR OIL
HERE AT HOME BECAUSE THE LEFT
WON'T LET HIM.
THE FOREIGN POLICY HE IS JUST
INCOMPETENT.
WRONG ABOUT EVERYTHING FOR 40
YEARS.
THERE IS A 1-2 PUNCH.
RADICAL ISLAM IS RAGING IN
AFGHANISTAN.
2022 COULD BE THE MOST DANGEROUS
YEAR FOR AMERICAN SINCE 1939 AND
THE WORLD AT LARGE.
>> Pete: I WANT TO GET TO THAT
IN A MOMENT.
WE FOR A VERY DANGEROUS MOMENT
IN THE WORLD WITH AN ABSENTEE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
IN 2022 DOES THIS LOOK BIGGER
THAN '94 AND 2010?
THE DISSATISFACTION IS SO HIGH.
REPUBLICANS HAVE A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
>> RIGHT.
IF WE DON'T BLOW IT.
THINK OF THE WORD BACK LASH.
THERE IS A BACK LASH AGAINST THE
MOST RADICAL DOMESTIC POLICY
AGENDA IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH A 50-50
SENATE AND A 5 SEAT MAJORITY.
THE DEMOCRATS MISPLAYED THEIR
HAND.
THEY THINK THEY HAVE A MANDATE
THEY DON'T HAVE.
IF THE REPUBLICANS CAN REMAIN
DISCIPLINED.
POLICY IS OUR FRIEND.
REMEMBER THE TRUMP YEARS ON THE
BORDER.
ISIS, AFGHANISTAN AND ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WE SHOULD TALK EVERY DAY ABOUT
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN OUR
POLICIES.
19 NOIR CAME IN WITH THE CLASS
OF '94.
WE HAD A CONTRACT WITH AMERICA
PROMISING PEOPLE WE WOULD DO
THESE 10 THINGS.
WE NEED AN AMERICAN FIRST AGENDA
TO RUN ON.
THEY SUCK IS PART OF THE DEAL --
SECURE THE BORDER, FINISH THE
WALL.
REBUILD THE MILITARY.
BECOME ENERGY INDEPENDENT AGAIN.
LOOKING FOR AN AMERICAN FIRST
AGENDA LED BY DONALD TRUMP WE
CAN RUN ON AS A TEAM AND POINT
OUT THE FLAWS OF THE BIDEN
AGENDA AND WE WILL CLEAN THEIR
CLOCK.
IN 1994 WE TOOK OVER THE HOUSE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 40 YEARS.
WE WILL EXCEED THAT.
>> Pete: YOU MENTIONED DONALD
TRUMP.
IS HE THE NOMINEE IN 2024 RIGHT
NOW?
>> YES, IF HE WANTS IT.
UNLESS THERE IS SOMETHING COMING
OUT OF LEFT FIELD.
IT'S HIS NOMINATION IF HE WANTS
IT.
THE REPUBLICAN BASE APPRECIATED
HIM.
WE DON'T APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
THINGS HE DOES SOMETIMES BUT
FROM A POLICY POINT OF VIEW HE
WAS THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
PRESIDENT SINCE REAGAN.
IT'S HIS NOMINATION IF HE WANTS
IT.
HE WILL BE IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN
2024 IF HE RUNS A DISCIPLINED
CAMPAIGN.
WHAT HE SHOULD DO IS REMIND
PEOPLE HOW HE SECURED THE BORDER
AND TOOK THE FIGHT TO I.C.E.
ISIS AND DESTROYED THE
CALIPHATE -- AND I THINK 2024 IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ELECTION TO
LOSE.
2022 IS A BLOW OUT YEAR FOR THE
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE IF WE TALK ABOUT POLICY.
>> Pete: YOU MENTIONED NOVEMBER
2022.
THAT'S A LONG WAY OFF.
OUR ENEMIES ARE LOOKING AT US.
ONE THE BEIJING OLYMPIC ARE
DONE, THE WORLD COULD LOOK
DIFFERENT.
WHAT IS THE NATIONAL SECURITY
REALITY WE ARE FACING?
>> THE IRANIANS WON'T GO BACK TO
THE TABLE IN GOOD FAITH.
THEY WILL TRY TO EXPORT A BOMB
AND ISRAEL WILL HAVE TO USE
MILITARY FORCE.
ARE THERE ANY RED LINES FOR
AMERICA ABOUT THE IRANIAN
NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
I WORRY ABOUT PUTIN AND UKRAINE
AND CHINA AND TAIWAN.
PETE, THANKS FOR ALL YOU HAVE
DONE TO REMIND AMERICANS TO OUR